I wonder if the day comes when I come here again.This is the
entrance to the land of black gold.Is it really
okay for me from Pulsatilla?There is no one other than you who is qualified to open this door.  [
Music]
Yes
[Music]
Luthia After all, the cute Kalibaraki who has been noticed is about to
take on something like this, so I came here to take on the
challenge.I came to
take back the Lumen Mountains and restore peace.So I'm
going.Wait.
We, the elves of Rosdor, will never forget this strong note.
I hereby swear to my true heart, Rare Silvia, that I will
repay your factory in due course.
May the good gods
and the spirits of courage follow your path.  I hope you have a basket